there's a great story of two Lumberjacks
where every morning they start chopping
wood at the same time and every day they
stop chopping wood at the same time and
every day one of The Lumberjacks
disappears for about an hour in the
middle of the day and every day he chops
more wood than the other guy and this
goes on for months and eventually the
one who works all day says I don't
understand every day we start at the
same time every day we stop at the same
time every day you disappear for about
an hour in the middle of the day and
every day you Chuck more wood than me
where do you go for that hour and the
other Lumberjack looks up and goes oh
I'll go home and sharpen my ax if you
take an infinite mindset it's not about
how much you can get done each day it's
how much you can get done over the
course of a career over the course of a
lifetime you gotta take vacations which
means you turn off your email and you
turn off your phone and you do not
connect to the office go sharpen your
act take a Friday afternoon off we have
something called duvet days in our
company where you wake up in the morning
and you just can't do it it's not like
vacation days where you plan ahead and
it's not like sick days like you're not
sick you just don't want to do it and
it's not feeling it you can do it and
you do responsibly you can't leave your
team in the Lurch obviously you have to
exercise responsible freedom but we give
people an opportunity instead of lying
and pretending that they have a stomach
bug because they just can't face the day
that they can just call up and say I'm
taking a duvet day and everybody goes go
go we got you you know go need
motivation watch your top 10 with
believe Nation
Michael and I make these videos because
you are probably the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you get that
Push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best Simon Sonic and my take on his
top ten it's a success enjoy
rule number two articulate your why I
can tell you what I went through which
is what set me on the journey
um to sharing the message of the why and
and helping people find theirs
um a why is like a is like a it's like a
compass Direction it tells you where
you're going
um we can live our lives by accident
which is kind of like getting in a ship
and just sailing or getting in a car and
just driving you'll absolutely see some
amazing things you'll stumble and upon
some amazing experiences but you don't
really have a sense of where you're
going any sort of Direction in other
words what's it all for what the why
does is it provides a path it provides a
map or a compass so you will still have
some of those amazing experiences but
now they have value and worth and
they're taking you towards something
else it's a journey towards something
when I learned my why
um I had this tremendous calm come over
me a sense of my confidence grew
um a sense that my life had more meaning
than I thought it had before and I had
now the choice of new way of viewing
decisions a filter through which to make
decisions which now I would ask myself
does this help Advance my why or not
does this help me stay on the path that
I'm supposed to be on or is this going
to be a random a random Adventure so the
Y provides Focus Direction meaning and
and confidence rule number three be the
best leader the best leader is actually
the best follower is even if they're at
the highest levels of the organization
they're still in service right it may
not be to a person but to a cause an
idea a vision whatever it is there's
still some sort of something that
they're beholden to and they're devoted
to and they're in service to
um so so followership is a thing
um and
um
not to belabor the Marine point but uh
you know Marines when they evaluate
their leaders they're looking good for
good leadership and good followership so
for example there when you go through
OCS officer candidates uh School
selection
um uh
when somebody's a for a task you know
chosen to be the leader of that group
for that task the the Marines are
watching the others as well so they're
looking to see that everybody's
contributing ideas and they're looking
to see that that leader takes in those
ideas but is decisive and and they're
looking to see that the the members of
the group if their idea isn't picked
they still give their all
to see that that the leader's idea is
successful and if it fails give it their
all to pick up the pieces and and see
what they can do as opposed to going I
told you right should have gone my way
right right I was right or sabotaging
because their idea didn't get picked so
they go all in so so good followership
is is as important as good leadership
that that we we respect that that
um when a decision is made we will we
will give our Blood Sweat and Tears to
see that the decision our leaders have
made will be successful and if it fails
we will help pick up the pieces because
that's the deal number four make an
impact having a sense of purpose cause
or belief for our work is what gives our
work and frankly Our Lives meaning
um you know when we die nobody wants the
the last balance in their checking
account written on their tombstone you
know uh nobody wants the last title on
their last business card on their
Tombstone we don't that's not how we
want to be remembered we want to be
remembered for the kind of person we
were in the lives of others you know
devoted mother loving father you know
these kinds of things
um and and we want to know that our work
uh had an impact in something bigger
than ourselves it's a very normal human
thing unfortunately a lot of people
don't start to think about thing those
things until later in their lives and
I've heard this I usually hear this from
senior Executives believe it or not
where they say you know I've had great
success and I've done all these things
but but I don't want my I don't want my
life to end on this chapter I I would
feel like I've done something wrong you
know and they want to make sure that
they're that they do something
powerful and impactful in the lives of
others that that's how they want to
close the book on their lives what I
love about this young generation is
they're starting to think about those
kinds of things now
you know it's not unique to a young
generation everybody wants their work to
matter and have meaning I think our
young generation is just more vocal
about it which is wonderful also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five show empathy so
you say I've met this person that I
really like how do I build trust well
you don't tell them all your secrets on
the first day right we all know that you
have to be vulnerable but but there is
there is a there's a timing you know and
it's a dance and it's and it's giving
somebody a little extra
um uh responsibility and seeing how they
do and if they screw up instead of
yelling at them be like all right try
again you know that we treat mistakes as
learning opportunities rather than you
know and a mistake is only when you keep
repeating the same error and you haven't
learned anything
um
where we practice empathy you build
trust with empathy as well so
um uh empathy uh in business looks like
this
um here's a traditional
scenario
somebody walks you know picks up the
phone or walks into their office when we
had when we did that
and says
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row
um
we've had this conversation before and
if you don't pick up your numbers in the
fourth quarter I don't know what's going
to happen right that's pretty normal
here's empathy injected into that
scenario hey your numbers are down for
the third quarter in a row we've had
this conversation before
um are you okay I'm worried about you
what's going on WOW right where it's
about the person not the performance
and so when again it goes back to that
listening and you you are not listening
until somebody else feels heard
those things you know seeing someone as
human understanding that we all have
stresses and strains and Egos and
insecurities and we bring all of that to
work
and though we still have to be uh
emotionally professional you know you
can't stick to meeting like this because
you're having a bad day that's
emotionally unprofessional
um though we still have to be
emotionally professional
um we're still human beings yeah and a
good leader uh recognizes that
and by the way somebody on a team
recognizes that too you don't have to be
a position of authority to be a good
leader you know because those who may be
higher in rank than us are also filled
with insecurity and fear and stress and
strain and ego and all that right and
it's okay to go up the chain of command
and say hey are you okay you know you
were really hard on us in that meeting
today instead of labeling them an
[ __ ] be like are you are you okay you
know and and by the way and that's the
dance it's like any relationship you
know it's not expected for one person in
an interpersonal relationship to to do
all the listening it's a dance and it
goes backwards and forwards and you know
you you you you meet empathy with
empathy and you meet listening with
listening rule number six focus on your
strengths I think very often companies
can risk becoming reactive to things
that happen in the marketplace which may
so here's a great example right let's
use a real life example Blackberry was a
really fantastic company who built a
really fantastic product with a really
clear sense it's a vision which is we
make strong secure extremely reliable
products and if you remember if you ever
had a BlackBerry
you could throw that thing across the
room drop it on the street and it just
didn't break it just kept working it was
the most reliable product on the
marketplace you could type on the full
qwerty keyboard without even looking
down you could send a hole in the email
and governments and big businesses loved
it because it was really secure and
really reliable
then the iPhone showed up and the iPhone
was the new shiny object
and blackberry instead of sticking to
their core and their beliefs became
distracted by the shiny popularity of
the iPhone which is a completely
different animal serving a completely
different audience and they started
trying to copy iPhone so they started
putting apps on their on their
blackberries which what did it do made
it slow and sluggish then they started
coming out with flat screens you're not
going to make a better iPhone than an
iPhone
um and they basically destroyed their
company because they completely went off
the reservation and and abandoned their
fantastic cause there could be two
marketplaces where you have the shiny
objective of the iPhone that we use in
our personal lives and our companies
prefer that we use a a Blackberry
because it's reliable it's safe and it's
and it's really really strong
um and we could have had two dominant
players for two dominant reasons like a
PC and a Mac two dominant players for
two dominant reasons for do two
different reasons but they didn't they
got distracted and I can imagine that
their that their business people were
saying you know business is moving at
light speed we have to react
um or we can work to advance our cause
in a different way and not become
distracted and that's part of the hard
thing which is are we stuck in our old
ways or are we actually sticking to our
sticking to our long-term Vision that's
that's part of the the difficulty of
business to know the difference rule
number seven be adaptable I always sort
of reject the concept of blunt honesty
you know
um you can be honest without being an
ass
um uh you know do I look fat in these
jeans I like the other genes better
that's an honest assessment without
making somebody feel bad uh for example
um and we also have to get good at
evaluating someone's personality some
people are more sensitive than others
and so a good leader is able to adapt
their style and how they uh offer
information so that um sometimes they
have to be a little more polite to some
and they can be a little more blunt with
another because their personalities can
take it
um what we want people to do is hear the
feedback hear the input
um uh and it's based on how they receive
it not how we like to give it we have to
be the adaptable ones
um as as as Leaders
um but he he's absolutely right that
good leadership starts with care and I
hear this all the time unfortunately
which is you know as a leader I didn't
get to uh I didn't get to choose my team
so why should I care about them or why
why should I trust them you know they're
not I didn't choose them well you didn't
get to choose your children you love
them
um and this is one of the the the the
the risks of leadership you know leaders
have to take the risk to care they have
to take the risk to trust first I've
never in my life heard a great leader
say proved to me why I should trust you
to their team it's the opposite a leader
takes the risk to trust and it's the
team who says prove to us why we should
trust you that's the correct hierarchy
um uh so so yes you don't you do have to
care you want to see you want to see
your people as human beings first
um you know they are not the problem
they may have a problem and inject a
little empathy into the into the
organization this is what what reflects
care so for example I'll give you one
one example
um uh so here's a pretty normal scenario
somebody walks into an office and says
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row we've had this
conversation before if you don't pick up
your numbers in the fourth quarter I
don't know what's going to happen
empathy uh changes that you walk into
their office and you say your numbers
are down for the third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before are
you okay what's going on I'm worried
about you that's empathetic that's the
expression of care that we we recognize
that someone may have a problem but they
are not the problem rule number eight
build great relationships I'll give you
a personal example the person who's who
sold me this property uh what it was the
seller's agent oh okay right he was
charming and nice and wonderful and
lovely and helpful and all the things
that I would expect and I warmed up to
him and he was
apparently helping me and then I
remember distinctly at the closing
he sat there with no personality all of
his charm had left
um all his friendliness had gone he
barely engaged with me he just wanted to
be there to collect his check so he
could get out of there
and I realized it was all fake it was
all for show it was all to butter me up
so that I would simply sign on the
dotted line and as a result I will never
work with him again as a buyer or a
seller
um I'll never list with him ever and I
probably will never work with that
company again because I realized they
just saw me as a number they never saw
me as a person in the first place
um he was an old white guy I mean that
should tell you a little bit of
something as well that that sort of
maybe how he was raised in the industry
um and by the way the mortgage broker
was no different you know uh he was
charming and wonderful and lovely and
helped me get a great rate etc etc and
then I remember after I closed he called
me and said congratulations and I said
oh thank you that's so nice of you and
he called me just to congratulate me on
closing on my house and then the first
thing he said to me was and if you know
anybody who's looking for a mortgage I'd
really appreciate the recommendation he
never called me to congratulate me he
called me because he wanted the referral
like give it a breath
you know like call me and congratulate
me and a week later asked me for the
referral and see let me tell you what
sucks about that can I say that what
sucks about that totally is that's
that one person yeah colored your
entirely and but this is finite versus
infinite okay he he could only see the
transaction he could only see get
business get more business get business
get more business what he didn't
understand is he's dealing with a human
being and the more there's a
relationship I will gladly recommend him
I will gladly introduce you to my guy
right
um now I'm completely agnostic because
if you're going to treat me like a
transaction I'm going to treat you like
a transaction if you're going to treat
me like a transaction I'm going to
squeeze you to get more money out of you
I want a lower rate I'm going to squeeze
the agents but if you treat me like a
human being I'll gladly pay a higher
rate because I want to work with you and
that's what infinite minded players
understand better which you don't have
to be the cheapest you don't have to
have the lowest rate or the lowest price
if you have a great relationship rule
number nine develop an infinite mindset
what does it mean to live an infinite
life
clearly our lives are finite we're born
we die we come we go
but life is infinite The Game of Life
will continue with us or without us
which means every single one of us has a
choice
we don't get to choose the nature of the
game Life is infinite we don't even get
to choose if we want to play in the game
or night once you're born you're in it
we get one choice
do you want to play with a finite
mindset
or do you want to play with an infinite
mindset
to play with a finite mindset means
waking up every day and say I'm going to
be the best I'm going to be better than
everybody else
I'm going to accumulate more power more
responsibility more money whatever it is
whatever whatever your metric is I'm
gonna I'm gonna get more than anybody
else me
and when you die you take none of it
with you
or we can choose to live our lives with
an infinite mindset
which means I'm going to leave this
world the school in better shape than I
found it it means I'm going to devote my
life to see that those around me rise
and we know that we're living with an
infinite mindset because our obsession
is seeing that we have an impact on the
lives of the people around us
we've all had teachers and some of you
are those teachers we're 20 or 30 years
from now I can go to one of your
students and say you're a remarkable
human being you've accomplished so much
in your life how did you become the
person you are today and they will tell
me your name
we all remember the teacher who believed
in us we all remember the teacher who
had our backs we all remember the
teachers saw something in us that nobody
else saw we've forgotten all the others
but we remember those couple
and that's what it means to live with an
infinite mindset it means we divert
ourselves to that mindset for everyone
in our lives that other teachers will
say that about us other principles will
say that about us other students will
say that about us our friends will say
that about us I am who I am today
because of you and I will commit to live
the same life that you taught me how to
live and you will literally live on but
your own your own lifestyle your own
lifetime
that when you're gone others will carry
your work
for you
this is what it means to live an
infinite life and it is just
a choice and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
aim for authenticity there are many
people in your industry who talk a good
game they talk about relationships but
let's be honest it's [ __ ] they just
want to make the transaction and move on
and uh they pretend that they care and
they pretend it's you know that they
care about the relationship when the
reality is it's one and done and on to
the next and that's what happened to me
I I had a mortgage broker uh he sold me
a mortgage he was recommended to me
that's how most of us meet somebody you
know
uh and uh he was very nice and charming
and
was there with me and then my my my sale
went through
and he called me up to congratulate me
and I was feeling a little warm and
fuzzy towards him and then as soon as he
congratulated me said and if you can
recommend me to anybody else I'd be
really grateful like
and he wasn't calling to congratulate me
he was calling to remind me to put in a
good word for him somewhere else like if
he actually cared about me and my house
then he would have just called me really
excited that I got my house and if he
wanted something from me he would have
waited a week a week or two to ask the
favor but the guy it became abundantly
clear to me I'm in the human behavior
business yes he never called me
because he cared about me yeah and by
the way I will never ever recommend him
because it was never I realized that I
was just a number on a spreadsheet
and so if you actually care about
building relationships then actually
build relationships yeah you know
um I remember when I was starting out in
my career I had a young
a little marketing consultancy
and I came from an industry that
pretended that they were good at
everything the marketing world like
literally they pretended they were good
at everything whether they were or
weren't and when I went out by myself
it was important to me to be honest and
clients would come and talk to me and
say we want to hire you to do all these
things and I'd say I'll do that when I'm
really good at that pretty good at that
I like doing that that I'm mediocre on
that I suck at I highly recommend you
hire another company to do that and I'm
happy to partner with them and it made
them want to do business with me more
because you said no because I told him
what I was good at what I was bad at
where I was super honest and we've all
had that experience where you want to
hire somebody and they go
you should let me introduce you to
something it happened to me recently
yeah I wanted a is it like something
silly yeah you know I needed wallpaper
yeah I I he highly recommended I called
him up he came and gave me a quote he's
like you know what I'm not the best at
this thing and he gave me the number of
somebody else yeah now all I want to do
is work with him again and I keep giving
out his phone number to other people
even though I actually never did work
with him yeah because what builds a
relationship is an honest broker honesty
is such a hard thing to get especially
in a transaction business especially in
a commodity business because it is just
volume and numbers yeah and that when
you actually find an honest one all you
want to do is help them build their book
of business even though you may never do
business with them and that's what a lot
of finite-minded folks in your business
don't get yeah which is you may never
sell me a mortgage but I'll become your
biggest champion
we always talk about being a stable
company we talk about investing in
stable companies and you know are you
are you stable and you think about
stability stability is is an immobile
object
you know uh and and so uh companies that
are built for stability yes they're able
to weather storms but they don't come
out stronger or better they just come
out they get through building a company
for resilience means that you go into
darkness but you're actually able to
adapt for New Times new technologies new
cultures New Politics new tastes and you
come actually out of the hard times
stronger than you went in
um Victorinox is a great example
Victorinox many of us know them by their
signature product which is the old Swiss
army knife and this company made
basically made a name for themselves on
this basically one line of product and
they had other product but this was this
was the core and then something happened
that they couldn't predict nor could
they uh prepare for which is September
11th happened and overnight we were
banned from taking their product in our
bags
in our hand luggage or in our pockets we
so many of us used to carry a Swiss army
knife in our pockets or just throw one
in our hand luggage like we all had one
you know every birthday for every
teenager they got at least one right
um every corporate gift you had a couple
of Swiss Army knives and now we were
banned from carrying them which means
you're less likely to buy one to give as
a gift and so their business their
business plummeted overnight
through no fault of their own through no
market conditions nothing predictable
but the genius of Victorinox is that
they were built for resilience and what
they did was they in good times instead
of giving away all the money and big
bonuses
in good times they actually saved a ton
of money and their attitude was
um good times don't last but neither do
bad times and if we want to get through
bad times we need to have we need we
need cash and so instead of panicking
and taking loans or whatever it is they
had their own stack of cash that it that
they'd been hoarding so they had a
little Financial resilience but then
they looked to other products and they
asked their people to help build up and
they started investing heavily in
watches now we have Victorinox watches
which are much more and it's still Swiss
made everything that they could do
everything that they knew how to do
clothing everything they leveraged their
brand heavily and they built it back up
also they protected all of their people
they actually made deals with companies
prior that if bad times ever happened
that that other companies would borrow
their employees which I thought was
genius so they didn't lose their jobs
they just did their job somewhere else
um and they completely reinvented their
company company now to this day their
Swiss army knife never really recovered
it came up back a bit but it's now not
the major product as a minor product
that they sell because they actually
came out stronger and reinvented
um and to be able to do that think about
that coming in as one kind of company
and coming out of another kind of
company very very rare and very very
special but very infinite minded when
you're trying to build uh trusting teams
it's you you recognize that you cannot
enforce certainty uh on people you can
offer goals people like goals
um but what's important is how we get
there not not just that we got there
think of it like uh think of it like um
trying to lose weight right there's
nothing wrong with setting arbitrary
goals or with arbitrary dates which is
by the way how we build our businesses
we want to hit x amount of dollars in
Revenue by probably the end of the year
because that's when we pay taxes it's a
completely arbitrary number somebody
might say we could do better than that
you're like you're right and then we
change the number right complete works
of fiction that so we're striving to hit
a work of fiction right
um
um and it's the same when we want to
lose weight I want to lose x amount of
pounds by X date arbitrary right and
we're doing all the things to do that
we'll you know we're exercising eating
well all the things we love standing on
the scale we love a metric there's
nothing wrong with that
um human beings need that we can't run
in a marathon without mile markers it's
actually unnerving we need to know how
fast and how far so the metrics are good
and let's say you hit your goal right
you hit your performance goal just as as
as you uh had articulated amazing you
feel incredible you feel like you've
succeeded here's the problem you have to
keep exercising for the rest of your
life right in other words you don't stop
doing the things that you were doing so
the game hasn't ended it was simply a
waypoint but what I think is more
interesting is what happens if you miss
your goal what happens if you don't lose
the amount of weight that you wanted on
that date and the and the answer is
nothing nothing happens because you're
probably way healthier than you are now
than you were you're probably on the
easily you can see the trend data you
can see you're well on your way to
hitting your goal you just pick the
wrong date you're easily going to hit it
in another month if you just stick to
your regime business is the same which
is sometimes we miss our goals but the
question is how what's the trend data
you know is the team working well
together is morale High
um is some of it out of our control you
know market conditions and things like
that things we didn't we didn't know
about and so if we happen to miss the
number the problem is is how are we
rewarding our people and so many of us
only reward Our People based on if they
hit the number but what if they're
begging borrowing and stealing what if
they simply Rush at the end of the
quarter to to drop their prices or have
some sort of promotion or or or or have
some some trickery they'll hit the
number
and then we bonus them which tells
everybody else I don't care how you hit
your numbers as long as you hit them
well guess what kind of behavior that's
going to reinforce inside our
organization
whereas if you look at the data the
trend data and you reward somebody who's
well on the path what we're telling you
is as long as you're doing a good job
you'll do well in this organization
leaders understand that they are not
responsible for the results they are
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the results and that
skill set is very very different than
just trying to get people to do the
thing that you know how to do better
than them because you've been doing it
your whole life you have to be clear and
open about what you stand for and just
like when you hire somebody
you want to make sure that when you hire
them that they share your values that
they believe in your vision you know
they don't just think it's corny you
know or marketing
um but rather that they they buy into it
and sometimes we'll make mistakes and
sometimes people will come and they fall
in love with it after the fact but we
it's you know we try on balance to bring
people that we believe will get along
with the people who work here because of
our values and our and our cause and so
too is it with with with suppliers
um I think that um uh or or clients it's
the same thing which is we stand for
what we stand for and our goal is to
attract people who believe what we
believe the the more vocal we are about
what we believe those people literally
will come to us or turn down a
competitor who may even be cheaper
because they would rather do business
with us and so it's okay to do business
with a supplier that doesn't believe
what we believe but we have to go in
with eyes open knowing full well that
this is just a transaction you offer a
decent product you give me a decent
price this is not going to be a lifelong
relationship this is a transactional
relationship
and when it's done I'm just going to
hold you to very different standards
right because when it's transactional
we're a little less patient when things
go wrong
um
and sometimes we kid ourselves you just
can't do that too often it's like if
you're living a healthy lifestyle you
can have chocolate cake just not too
often
um so yeah I think the more vocal you
are the more you attract and then you
have to make decisions like you're
hiring people because they're going to
become a member of your family as well
this is the difference between the
short-term finite minded and the
long-term infinite minded the
finite-minded is it the cheapest today
is it the best relationship today and
pay no attention to the secondary or
tertiary effects and definitely pay no
attention to what will happen in five
years whereas that long-term minded
infinite-minded uh player
um looks at some it's it's looks at
something and and looks at someone and
says well you know you're not the
cheapest but I think we're going to get
along just fine and over the course of
time the quality of work will far away
what have you paid a friend of mine
who's a consultant loves to joke about
her clients that they never have the
time or money to do it right the first
time but they always have the time and
money to do it again
and I think when you're infinite minded
you consider those factors from the from
the beginning let's reinforce that point
because I think it's an important one
that fulfillment is a right and not a
privilege and when we go out with our
friends for dinner or when we used to be
able to do that
um uh uh you know you sit around and
somebody says I love my job and
everybody goes oh my God you're so lucky
like they won something that statement
should be the norm not the exception we
should all get to go to dinner and say I
love my job and it's the one person who
says I don't that's that that we can
that we can intervene
um so yeah I believe it is a right and
we have a responsibility ourselves to to
find a a place where we want to work
with the people that we would work with
rather than just taking the biggest
salary
um that we have a responsibility to take
care of the people around us and we have
a responsibility to speak up and ask our
our leaders to work with us and create a
place where people want to come to work
where we where there's a safe space for
us to take care of each other and feel
taken care Arab so there's Mutual
responsibility all around
so when you say you know how do we do it
well it's it requires constant work it's
like how do you stay healthy well I can
give you a whole list of things you have
to do you have to eat right you have to
nurse your personal relationships you
have to get enough sleep you have to
exercise you have to meditate you have
to be mindful you know there's a little
there's like 30 things and you can't do
all those things well all the time it's
a striving
um and uh and when one's doing well
sometimes one one thing falls off it's a
striving and it's the same the the
pursuit of fulfillment is a striving you
know I I think it's you know this is why
I make the distinction between
fulfillment and happiness you know to
seek happiness is a lot easier because
happiness is fleeting you know you you
you get a new job you're happy you get a
raise you're happy you win a new piece
of business you're happy you're given a
gift you're happy you know somebody says
something nice to you you're happy and
that feeling goes away
no nobody nobody walks around with a
sense of happiness for a job they got
four years ago it's gone
um where fulfillment is different
fulfillment you can feel fulfilled by
your work even if you're not enjoying it
today
you can feel fulfilled by your work even
if you're having a bad a bad day you
know or or one of your colleagues is
grumpy you can still be fulfilled by the
work it's more it's more uh it's it's
more infinite it's more constant and so
um whereas happiness is you know the
things that lead up to it it sounds more
like an event fulfillment is a striving
it's a lifestyle and you do all these
things like having a just cause like
building trusting teams and working to
be the leader you wish you had in other
words you see your life as a life of
service to those around you whether
you're in a company whether you're an
employee whether you're a leader or if
you're just a parent that you see your
life in service you know to your spouse
your partner or your and your kids and
indeed your community what makes a
community highly functional is that we
view uh that every single person within
that Community sees their responsibility
to serve the community rather than
standing around demanding the community
does something for them let's say
there's one person who started their own
little business a little consultancy
right got my shingle out I'm a
consultant right and everywhere they go
they keep telling you that they're
better than everyone else
uh they keep telling you they're smarter
than everyone else they keep telling you
that you know the big the problem with
the big companies is is they don't have
the flexibility I'm it actually gets the
point of being annoying to the point
that we don't want to actually work with
them because we don't believe them right
because
um now let's let's change the change the
scenario you meet that same person and
and they introduce themselves look
there's a lot of good good Consultants
out there
um some of them are a lot better than me
um but I wake up every single day to be
a better version of what I do today than
I did yesterday and I can tell you the
advice I give today is even better than
it was yesterday and the advice I'm
going to give tomorrow is even better
because for me it's an education and
that's why I love working with
open-minded wonderful clients who are
partners because what we end up doing is
growing together
right now that's one person think about
how appealing that person is they've
actually told you
that you may actually get as good or
better advice somewhere else but it's
who they are and who they're being in
the disposition that they bring that
make them way more trustworthy and uh us
wanting to work with them
um and it's the same for big companies
it's got nothing to do with the size of
the company which is it's called
humility and honesty I remember young in
my career I experienced this myself when
I when I went off and hung my shingle
out and I was a little I had a little
marketing company a little marketing
consultancy I remember going into
meetings and the client would say we
want you to do all of this for us and
I'd say I'm really good at that pretty
good at that okay at that really bad at
that I highly recommend you hire
somebody else to do that and I'm happily
partner with them for them to do that
and the clients wanted to work with me
more
not even though I just told them I can't
do that only because I was the only one
who was honest everybody else they talk
to big or small told them that they were
great at everything which is just not
true nobody's great at everything and uh
and so it's amazing when you take the
risk to be honest it pays dividends in
the trust that you build I think courage
is external right the reason someone has
courage to jump out of an airplane is
because there's a parachute on their
back it's the external thing
a world famous trapeze artist would
never try a brand new death-defying act
for the first time without a net it's
the net that gives them the courage
uh you know the Navy Seals are
considered one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet and a former
seal was asked what kind of person makes
it into the seals
and he said
I can't tell you the kind of person that
makes it in but I can tell you the kind
of person that doesn't make it
he said the Star College athletes who
have never really been tested to the
core of their being
none of them making it
he said the preening leaders who like to
delegate everything
none of them make it in
he says the guys that show up with
hulking muscles covered in tattoos
because they want to show you how tough
they are
none of them make it in he sent it he
said some of the guys who make it in are
skinny and scrawny he said some of the
guys who make it in you see them
shivering out of fear
he said but every single one of the guys
who makes it in when they're emotionally
exhausted when they're physically
exhausted when they have absolutely
nothing left to give
somehow some way they're able to dig
down deep inside themselves to find the
energy to help the guy next to them
in other words the reason these
organizations and these people have the
courage to do remarkable things is not
because of their internal strength it's
because they have the absolute
confidence that there is someone to the
left of them and someone to the right of
them that cares about them
um and they will know that and it's the
quality of the relationships that we
maintain professionally and personally
that give us the courage to do difficult
things
Isaac Stern the famous violinist said
music is what happens between the notes
well something like trust happens
between the meetings you know we few
people think about the importance of
building trust when they go to work or
the what I need to do today to build
trust with somebody like that doesn't
really go through people's minds but we
have Chit Chat as we walk into the
meeting we've Chit Chat when we walk out
of the meeting and we see somebody the
whole they're like oh meant to tell you
something or you knock on someone's door
and be like got a minute and all those
little innocuous interactions over the
course of time like any relationship
build trust it's about setting up the
computer and setting up zoom and having
a work session with somebody you know
like we're not working on the same thing
but I want to work with somebody a work
buddy or having a lunch with somebody
over Zoom or a Monday morning huddle
where we talk about what's on our hearts
and minds but we do not talk business on
purpose or Friday uh cocktails that are
just voluntary but the most important
one is to just pick up the phone and
call people and say hey how are you
that level of empathy just check in on
someone and I think we neglect it
because we get mired in the day-to-day
but you know one of you know if you're
organized or disorganized you know
literally keep a list of your team on a
little card next to your computer and
just you know go through it and have I
called this person a while and talk to
us but I'm just going to call and check
in it doesn't matter if something's
wrong or not wrong just check in on them
you know don't wait for something to
Break
um and let people know that they're uh
that there's connection and there's a
way to reach out and say I need help
um because if if if and and the most
important thing is for leaders to be
honest and open about their need to ask
for help
and that that'll work I think one of the
things that the the pandemic revealed
quite frankly was the weakness of so
many corporate cultures I mean we're
seeing the great resignation happening
and if you read articles or listen to
some of the Talking Heads you know the
prevailing thought is well they're
getting you know checks from the
government so they're not encouraged to
come back to work
um or they're pursuing their dreams you
know which which we've seen as well in
our own company somebody wants to go be
a screenwriter and even though we have a
great relationship and they love their
job they they want to pursue their
dreams but the other the other thing
that I think is is underlying that it's
that it's missing that these these
commentaries are missing is that
um the cultures uh may have been weaker
than we like to think they are
um uh that the the sense of belonging
that people have when they would come to
work is actually a lot a lot more
tenuous than we'd like to believe so the
the the bond that's allowing them to go
off and do other things is is easily
broken I think strong cultures when
there's a strong corporate culture we
recognize that I can pursue my dreams
and work because I love it here and I
know my team is supportive of me
becoming a screenwriter or something and
I can do both or even though I'm making
money potentially even more money
there's so much more I get from my work
you know the camaraderie the love the
support I get all of this training on
how to be a better listener and a better
Communicator which is helping me in my
marriage and helping me with my kids and
I don't want to lose that plus I I have
my I have close friends at work
um and I can speak up and say hey I'm
I'm being offered more money from the
government is there anything you can
help you know the point is it becomes a
conversation rather than a rather than a
resignation so I think one of the things
that we're missing is this might be a
wake-up call for a lot of companies that
our culture is just not as strong as we
think they are you know it's been spoken
about for years that Millennials you
know and now gen Z are just not loyal to
work they bounce around from job year to
year to year well is that them or is
that us maybe if we had stronger
cultures they wouldn't want to leave
maybe if we offered them more than some
simply Financial incentives for hitting
certain numbers that they'd want to stay
maybe if they felt that they were
growing like as human beings there would
be things that were more appealing to
them than simply simply a bigger
paycheck somewhere else
um so I actually think it's it's a it's
a big wake-up call frankly
um uh that that we we should go back and
look at our cultures and say are we are
we as good as we think we are you cannot
have Innovation or progress without
failure it doesn't exist and if you
truly aren't failing as you're trying to
innovate then you're probably not
pushing very hard because you haven't
broken anything you're making very very
safe choices we could never put a person
on the moon without a bunch of rockets
blowing up first like I met a CFO once I
asked him the priorities of the company
and he said efficiency and Innovation
and I laugh and say well good luck with
that you know Innovation is inherently
inefficient because it requires
experimentation the experimentation
requires failure much is said about fail
fast I actually don't like the term
failure the problem with the word
failure is it's like the word cancer
it's too broad like if you have stage
four liver cancer or you have a mild
melanoma those things are both called
cancer but they are clearly not the same
thing and the same thing is when we hear
the word fail some people think failure
means experimentation but a lot of
people think failure means catastrophe
and so when we tell our company failure
is good fail fast that literally scares
people we don't want to fail so I think
we need a new word we want to avoid
failure failure is catastrophic and it
should be avoided but Falling I think we
should encourage when a kid falls off a
bicycle we didn't tell them they failed
we tell them they fail and what do we
tell them get back up and try again so I
don't want to tell people they fail I
want to see people they fail and I want
to encourage them to try again and brush
off their knees so I think we should
fall and fall often and I will judge the
quality of innovation not necessarily by
if you fell but how quickly you can pick
yourself back up and try again I think
some people turn off the humanity when
they go to work
um you know they they they may be you
know loving parents and loving friends
and loving you know children to their
own parents and yet for some reason
there's a switch that they think that
that's irresponsible to do at work now
I'm not talking about necessarily
wearing your heart on your sleeve every
day there is something called emotional
professionalism you know if you're
having a bad day you can say listen I'm
a little off my game today but you can't
sit in the meeting with your arms folded
and be grumpy and give one word answers
that's that's emotionally unprofessional
you know you can have hard feelings but
you can't go around screaming and
yelling at people you know you can have
um so I think there's a there's
emotional professionalism but I think
for some reason especially as people
make their way up the ranks
um they think that expressing any kind
of emotion is a sign of weakness even
that word vulnerability we talk you know
it's such a common word now being talked
about in in the business world that you
have to be vulnerable to this day it
makes some people feel very
uncomfortable I don't want to be
vulnerable well all vulnerability means
um is saying things like I don't know or
I need help or I'm overwhelmed or can
you you know can you help me do this
because I don't know how to do this or
I've been promoted to a position where
maybe I need more training and the
reason we're afraid of saying that is
for fear that it makes us look weak
which will then damage our careers the
reality is the total opposite by saying
I don't know means someone can help us
but instead we choose to lie hide and
fake very often which eventually gets
revealed enough stress piled on on that
lying hiding and faking collapses either
professionally or personally we either
we either feel the stress or or the
projects that we're working on start to
go haywire and very often when we get to
those points everybody knows anyway
um and uh the amazing thing that I've
learned is when you say can somebody
help me we're surrounded by people who
love would love to help us they just
didn't think we needed it because we
acted as if we didn't so I think a large
part of it is is quite frankly fear fear
that if I express these things that'll
that people will think I'm not qualified
for my job
um uh where the the uh the the the
opposite is true and remember when you
are in a position of leadership you
don't actually have to be better at
doing the job that the people you lead
you have to be responsible for taking
care of them to make sure they're good
at their job but for some reason we
think that
um I have to be better than you at your
own job because I'm the leader
completely false I just have to make
sure that you're equipped you have the
tools the training and and the
psychological safety to come to be the
best you can be even if it's better than
me when the pandemic struck I mean my
book came out a few months before the
pandemic and so for from a from a for
someone like me who like who loves to
observe and like whether this stuff is
true or not you know you sort of go you
know you sort of Wonder is everything
going to hold up or not
uh and as an existential Flex uh is
something that I predicted would happen
either zero once or at the absolute most
twice in a career but when covet
happened we all went through it at the
same time existential flexibility is is
that you're able to make a profound
uh 180 degree strategic shift in order
to continue to advance your cause in
other words stay relevant
um this is not about the daily
flexibility of business this is we're
talking profound strategic shift here
um and sometimes brought on by pandemic
sometimes brought on by changing
technology or politics or culture or
tastes
um but you're able to adjust
um so for example it's
um Apple Steve Jobs when they're
developing technology in One Direction
they just and they discover this thing
called the graphic user interface that
they did not invent and they decide to
walk away from millions of dollars spend
an accountless man hours in order to
focus on a different uh strategic uh
position because jobs believe that that
was a better way to advance his cause of
empowering individuals to use uh
personal computers
um that's that's existential flux how do
we replace our judgment with curiosity
um so there's a simple technique there
are simple techniques to do this one is
write yourself a little reminder put a
little sticky on your computer that says
be curious or ask questions you'll be
amazed how well that works but
especially in times when we're judging
especially when we're in groups of
leaders we're in meetings you know we
can snowball into judgment really
quickly let's say someone's performances
in Decline immediately they're lazy you
know they're stupid they don't
understand they're a problem child all
it takes is one person to break that
judgment and say well maybe they're
going through something and there is a
technique where when you believe when
you start to form a narrative about
someone or about something that you
force yourself to come up with 21
possible Alternatives of what could be
going on in their life so are they lazy
absolutely that's absolutely a
possibility are they a problem child are
they toxic absolutely are they going
through is are there kids struggling at
school maybe do they have problems in
their family maybe someone's sick maybe
do they have medical issues that they're
hiding from us that that they're too
embarrassed about maybe like my point is
is can you go through through the
exercise of writing 20 or 21 alternative
stories of what could be happening and
all of a sudden we find ourselves
talking about and treating that person
differently and it doesn't just come
about people it's also about decisions
we're making at work and all again in a
meeting all it takes is one person to
raise a question of what if
um and as Leaders The more we start
asking each other and ourselves what if
or what are the opportunities what are
the possibilities we'll find ourselves
doing that with our people that when
they come to us instead of us correcting
them and telling that they're wrong
raising questions but believe it or not
simply having a little reminder to be
curious is is really important when we
are willing to put ourselves at risk to
be there for someone right don't worry
if this goes south I will be there for
you
um which may mean working late it may
mean working extra hours it may be
putting our reputations on the line I
mean there's a lot of things that that
takes
um but when we genuinely promise to be
there for someone
um
um uh and and it has to be genuine uh
because if it gets tested it's it's very
easy to find out if it was genuine or
not
um but if it's genuine then then it's
repaid remarkably let me give you a
silly example
um let's say that um so I talk about
this um sometimes which is the giving of
time and energy is more powerful than
the giving of money you can't build
trust with money so paying somebody
bonuses and giving somebody a big salary
though feels nice is not earning or
building any trust whatsoever you cannot
pay for trust
um and here's the example
um let's say you're moving house
um and one of your friends says you know
what I want to help you we've been
friends for years
um I'm gonna pay for the moving van
here's five thousand dollars and the
moving van let me know how it goes have
a great move that's really generous
right
another friend says you know what I want
to help you move and they come over the
week before and they're sitting in your
house packing boxes they're
sweat dripping down their brow they're
there with you all day they're there to
help load the truck they're there to
help unload the truck they're they're
there
um uh to unwrap everything right they
paid zero money
they give you time and energy which are
non-redeemable Commodities money we make
money we spend money we make money back
it's a redeemable commodity time and
energy are non-redeemable Commodities
and so when someone gives us something
that they cannot get back
it has a much more powerful effect on
how we feel so now both those people
call you another time and say I need
your help which one are you more apt to
help you want to give you money or the
one who gave you time and energy and
that this this is a good lesson for
leadership as well giving our time and
energy is often more powerful than
simply just throwing money at someone
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Gary vaynerchuk
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there there's a lot of
push towards being a workaholic and hard
work is a learned behavior I see it in
my team I've seen it in the thousands of
employees I've had which is the closer
they are to the Sun the harder they work